what is assembly theory please send me
some slides there's a there's a big sexy
paper coming out probably
maybe i don't know we've almost finished
it
um
almost almost that's like that's also a
summary of science we're almost done
yeah
we're almost done
the history of science we are ready to
start an interesting discussion with our
peers
right you're the machine that created
the object and we'll see what an object
takes
all right so what what is assembly
theory um yeah well i think i think the
easiest way for people to understand is
to think about um
assembly and molecules although the
theory is very general doesn't just
apply to molecules and this was really
leasing site so it's kind of funny that
i'm explaining it but um okay
okay all right i'm ready i'm ready i'm
ready tell me where i get the check
marks minus but it's your theory as well
yeah i know but ima imagine a molecule
um and then and then you can you know
break the molecule apart into elementary
building blocks they happen to be bonds
and then you can think of all the ways
for molecular assembly theory you can
think of all the ways of building up the
original molecule so there's all these
paths
that you can assemble it and the sort of
rules or assemblies you can use pieces
that have been generated already
so it has this kind of recursive
property to it
and so that's where kind of memory comes
into assembly theory and then the
assembly index is
the shortest path in that space so it's
supposed to be the minimal amount of
history that the universe has to undergo
in order to assemble that particular
object and the reason that this is
significant is we figured out how to
measure that
with a mass spec
in the lab and we had this conjecture
that if that minimal number of steps was
sufficiently large
it would indicate that you required a
machine or a system that had information
about how to assemble that specific
object because the combinatorial space
of possibilities is getting
exponentially large as the assembly
index is increasing so just sorry to
interrupt but so that means there's a
sufficiently high assembly index
that
if observed in an object
is an indicator that
something
life like created it or is the object
itself life like
um both
but you might want to make the
distinction that a water bottle is not
life
but it would still be a signature that
you were in that domain of physics
and i might be alive
so um
so there will be potentially a lot of
arguments about where the line
at which assembly index
uh
does interesting stuff start to happen
the point is we can make all the
arguments but it should be
experimentally observable and and we can
talk more about that part of it but the
the point i want to make about it is
there was always this intuition that i
had that there should be some complexity
threshold in the universe above which
you would start to say whatever physics
governs life actually becomes operative
and i think about it a little bit like
we have planks constant which you know
and we have the fine structure constant
and then this sort of assembly threshold
is basically
another sort of
uh potentially constant of nature it
might depend on specific features of the
system like but which we debate about
sometimes but um
but then when you're past that you have
you have to have some other explanation
than the current explanations we have in
physics because now you're in high
memory
uh the things actually require time for
them to exist and time becomes a
physical variable the the path to the
creation of the object is the memory so
you need to consider that
yeah but but the point is that's a
feature of the object
so it's it's it so when i think of all
the things in this room uh you know we
see the the projection of them as a
water bottle but assembly theory would
say that this is a causal graph of all
the ways the universe can create this
thing that's what it is as an object and
we're all interacting a causal grasp and
and most of the creativity in the
biosphere is because a lot of the
objects that exist now are huge in their
structure across time four billion years
of evolution to get to us and so is it
possible to look at me
and
infer the history that led to me
if me as a human you as an individual
might be hard you as a
representative of a population of
objects that have high assembly with
similar causal history and structure
that you can communicate with i.e other
humans you can refer a lot probably yeah
we'll stay with them which we do
genomically even i mean it's not like
like we have a lot of information and
that's we can reconstruct histories from
assembly's saying something slightly
deeper yeah one thing to add i mean it's
not just about the object but the
objects occur and not just objects for a
high assembly number because you can
have random things that have a higher
semi number they must have there must be
a number of identical copies so you know
you're getting getting away from the
random because you could take a snapshot
this is why it's not i hate entropy i
love entropy when used correctly but
it's about the problem of entropy you
have to have a labeler and so so you can
label the beginning and the end to start
and the finish you know what you can do
in assembly is say oh i have a number of
objects in abundance they all have these
features and then you can infer
and one of the things that we debated a
lot particularly during lockdown because
i almost went insane trying to crush the
produce the assembly equation so we came
up with the assembly equation i had just
imagine this so you have this string
where
oh
actually it makes me makes me sick
trying to remember it was so it did my
head in for a long time
yeah because i couldn't
so if you just have a string of say
words say you know a series of words
series of letters so you just have a aaa
bbb ccc ddd and you and you find that
object you just just have four a's four
b's four c's four d's together boom then
and that really that you measured that
so you physically measured that string
of letters
then what you could do is you could
infer
sub graphs of maybe the four a's the
four b's the four c's and four c's we
don't see them
in the real world you just infer them
and i really got stuck with that because
there's a problem to try and work out
what's the difference between a long
you know
a physical object and this assembly
space the object so that we realized the
best way to put that is infer in time
that so although we can't infer your
entire history we know at some point the
four a's were made the four b's was made
the four c's were made in four d's were
made and they all got added together and
and that's one real really interesting
thing that's come out the theory but the
the killer when we knew we were going
beyond
um
and um beyond standard complexity
theories was incredibly successful
is that um we realized we could start to
measure these things for real across
domains
so the assembly index is actually an
intrinsic property of all stuff that you
can break into
components
particularly molecules are good because
you can break them up into smaller
molecules into atoms
the challenge will be making that more
general across all the domains but we're
working on it right now and i think the
theory will do that
you